[Musik]
brutale polizeigewalt tag für tag in
weißrussland seit einem monat
protestieren die menschen gegen das
manipulierte ergebnis der
präsidentschaftswahl und gegen den
terror des diktators alexander
lukaschenko
der lässt inzwischen auf demonstranten
schießen
nicht nur in der hauptstadt minsk
diese telegramm userin berichtet
auspresst ein board review
sie schießen dieses video zeigt wie der
demonstrant alexander pfarrei kowski am
abend des zehnten august erschossen wird
mutmaßlich von polizisten der
sondereinheit almaz
über den telegramm kanal nicht da werden
viele der videos gepostet
wir erreichen den chefredakteur von
echter roman botta serbisch im exil in
warschau die erschießung von
unbewaffneten menschen und mindestens
fünf wurden bereits umgebracht ist ein
kriegsverbrechen gegen das bella
russische volk dafür müssen die
verantwortlichen vor ein internationales
tribunal gestellt werden
und ich hoffe dass die schuldigen
bestraft werden
zahlreiche fotos und videos aus belarus
hat fabian schwalm ausgewertet
rüstungsexperte bei greenpeace
er entdeckte bei belarussischen
polizeieinheiten eine bestimmte waffe
die pistole sieg sauer p 2 266 aber muss
man sagen dass es sich hierbei um eine
deutsche firma handelt die von einer
deutschen holding geführt wird dies ist
die l and holding in emsdetten die
eigentümerin von sechs sauer ist es ist
also ganz klar dass wir hier eine
deutsche waffe eines deutschen
herstellers in den händen der bella
russischen polizei nachweisen konnten
wie kommen deutsche waffen in die hände
einer diktatur gegen das regime in
belarus hatte die eu im juni 2011 ein
waffenembargo verhängt wegen schwerer
menschenrechtsverletzungen des diktators
alexander lukaschenko auf nachfrage
erklärt die bundesregierung gegenüber
frontal 21
an die genehmigungserteilung für exporte
von klein und leicht waffen in
drittstaaten legt die bundesregierung
schon seit einigen jahren besonders
respektive maßstäben aus
regierungskreisen erfahren wir die
pistole sieg sauer p 2 26 und weitere
deutsche waffen würden schon seit 20
jahren nicht mehr nach belarus
exportiert stimmt das
das belle russische staatsfernsehen
präsentiert im märz 2012 einheiten des
innenministeriums und ihre waffen im
film heißt es vor einem halben jahr
wurden für die kämpfer des
innenministeriums pistolen bei einer
schweizerisch deutschen firma gekauft
es ist die deutsche pistole sieg sauer p
226 informationen erlangt die auf einen
eine lieferung nach dem embargo 2011
hindeuten und zwar dass sie im herbst
2011 genau solche pistolen von 6 sa
erworben haben
ein erlass des bella russischen
innenministeriums vom 25 februar 2009 10
belegt eine ausbildungseinheit der
polizei bekam 15 pistolen 6226 eine
andere 2
deutsche pistolen für den diktator
wir fragen mehrfach nach beim deutschen
hersteller sieg sei keine antwort wie
die pistolen trotz embargos nach belarus
kamen bleibt unklar
fest steht bei einem schießtraining
russischer und bello russischer
geheimdienste feiert ein schütze des
belle russischen geheimdienstes kgb mit
der deutschen pistole sig sauer p 2 26
beim gleichen training üben die bälle
russischen kräfte mit einer weiteren
deutschen waffe der maschinenpistole mp5
entwickler der mp 5 ist die deutsche
firma heckler & koch in oberndorf in
baden württemberg der waffenhersteller
erklärt es gab und gibt keine
geschäftlichen beziehungen von heckler &
koch nach weißrussland belarus aber die
türkei baut die maschinenpistole mp5 von
heckler & koch seit mehr als 30 jahren
in lizenz als dienstwaffe für
sicherheitskräfte die bundesregierung
erlaubte dem türkischen
staatsunternehmen mk ii die produktion
der maschinenpistole mit einer
entscheidenden auflage dazu teilte die
bundesregierung dem parlament mit
der von der firma heckler & koch mit dem
türkischen unternehmen mk abgeschlossene
lizenzvertrag seine produktion nur für
den eigenbedarf vor
im klartext exporte der in der türkei
produzierten mp5 in andere staaten sind
ausnahmslos verboten bis heute
recherchen von frontal 21 bei unruh dem
waffenexport register der uno belegen
die türkei exportierte noch 2016 nach
belarus 59 m p53 maschinenpistolen und
missachtete damit das ausfuhrverbot der
bundesregierung für die türkischen
lizenz waffen
die bundesregierung hat jetzt eigentlich
nur die möglichkeit politisch auf die
türkei einzuwirken und zu sagen dass das
nicht passieren soll und gleichzeitig
die zweite ebene auf der sie agieren
kann ist weitere genehmigungsanträge von
deutschen firmen für lieferungen in die
türkei abzulehnen um auch dadurch druck
auszuüben dass die türkei nicht mehr
weiter
500 weißrussland liefert nachfrage beim
regierungssprecher wie reagiert die
bundesregierung darauf dass die türkei
gegen die abmachungen die zensierte
deutsche kriegswaffen dach de la rosa
polizei werden auch nach dem boykott
noch geliefert hat ich habe dazu jetzt
keine informationen die müsste ich ihnen
nachreichen ich weiß nicht ob die
kollegen des wirtschaftsministeriums
dazu die kollegen vom
wirtschaftsministerium hatte frontal
vergangene woche bereits zweimal
schriftlich angefragt
ich habe die entsprechenden
informationen nicht dabei musste ich
nach reichen
am abend wird nachgereicht auf die frage
was die regierung gegen waffenexporte
der türkei ein belarus unternommen hat
teilt das ministerium mit
zum konkret angesprochenen einzelfall
bitte haben sie dafür verständnis dass
wir zur konkreten rüstungsexport
entscheidungen der bundesregierung keine
auskunft geben können
arnold wallraff war bis vor drei jahren
deutschlands oberster kontrolleur für
waffenexporte die lizenzproduktion
deutsche kriegswaffen in der türkei
sieht er heute kritisch angesichts der
fakten und des tatsächlichen verhaltens
der türkei war es keine gute idee dass
der türkei in einem lizenzvertrag zu
gestatten in der zukunft leute dass die
konsequenzen haben als sanktion dann
keine lizenzen mehr oder vielleicht
sogar noch eine stufe weiter
als sanktion überhaupt keine
rüstungsgüter exporte in die türkei
mehr in deutschland entwickelte waffen
bei den truppen von lukaschenko
niemand kann ausschließen dass sie
eingesetzt werden bei der unterdrückung
der demokratiebewegung in belarus